now Palestinians protesting against the
expansion of settlements have been
attacked by the Israeli military
villagers in umsafar north of Ramallah
say that soldiers beat dozens of
demonstrators and used tear gas and stun
grenades to disperse them they had
gathered there to stop settlers from
seizing their land well let's speak to
our correspondent on the ground Laura
Khan she's in Ramallah Laura talk us
through what's been happening there in
umsafa
absolutely Anastasia now I'm currently
in Ramallah this happened about 12
kilometers away on the outskirts of
Ramallah we've spoken to the Village
Council today now they said that a
number of activists had come to join
them internationally and from Israel in
order to support them in protests
against a new illegal Israeli Outpost
that was set up on the Hills just
outside of the village now they've been
protesting this for around two weeks but
it's quite unusual it's happening more
often now the Israeli soldiers came in
they surrounded The Village Council and
they started beating the protesters but
usually the protests will come to them
first and then we'll see those kind of
clashes they then fired tear gas and
started firing live bullets in the air
so far we haven't had any reports of
injuries but we do know that the illegal
Outpost has been uninstalled and taken
away Laura despite the clearly Rising
tension it does sound like settlement
construction is still ongoing around
there
settlement construction is mushrooming
across the occupied West Bank just the
other day we were driving from Janine to
ramallet it's a two-hour drive and we're
seeing settlements on almost every Hill
there are around 700
000 settlers living inside the West Bank
these settlements are illegal under
international law and the outposts under
Israeli laws so it's certainly become a
fact on the ground and because and also
the seller attacks are becoming more and
more frequent we're seeing people coming
down into the villages houses have been
burnt in the last few weeks and also
there's been an increase in Palestinian
attacks against settlers so it's all
part of the escalation that we've seen
this year but according to the Israeli
NGO piece now we're seeing a record
number of settlement units approved
across the occupied West Bank
with the latest Wars from the ground in
Ramallah thank you Laura